hi I'm Eric Voss and as we crossed into
this final stretch of our long wait for
the fourth Avengers movie we just got
confirmation of a major detail regarding
the ending of infinity war so when they
announced acquired all six Infinity
stones snapped his fingers half of all
life destined from existence
some people just it on-screen some we
found out later dusted off screen and
some not even important enough to
mention others fates were just left a
mystery but now we know that two key
characters actually survived and spoiler
warning in case you don't wanna know dr.
Erik Selvig and his associate Darcy
Lewis from before movies have survived
and while they may seem like minor
players so big as we saw in the first
Avengers movie this is a guy who's been
pretty central to the Infinity stones in
the main timeline of all these events
and actually rewatching Thor the dark
world an easter egg has resurfaced
online that could make solving survival
very very important but first how do we
know Selvig and Darcy survived well
there's an upcoming book called Marvel's
Avengers Infinity Ward the cosmic quest
vol 2 aftermath and its author Brandon T
Snyder tweeted an image of the back
cover description which again makes this
a tweet down it's been a minute okay the
plot summary goes as follows
a deadly threat emerged from the cosmos
and it was fulfilled in the wake of
Thanos is horrifying success the people
of Earth are left reeling in despair and
confusion without any logical
explanation for the blip out event those
remaining must pick up the pieces dr.
Erik Selvig and his associate Darcy
Lewis are determined to find and
understand the cause of this devastation
with the team friends both old and new
they embark on a pursuit of knowledge
eager to discover the links between
their own paths and the stones that
decimated half of humanity the Infinity
stones little do they know what
Bufo who threatens to destroy them all
is here's where this is interesting so
Vic is one of those fascinated into Cu
super nerds like dr. strange she knows a
lot more than he's letting on also like
dr. strange a lot of that knowledge
comes from divine insight gained from an
infinity stone dr. strange of course
possessed the time stone and Selvig
remember was influenced by the mind
stone it was contained inside Loki's
scepter when he was tapped in the first
Avengers and it filled his noggin with
cosmic wisdom and as we saw at the
beginning at the dark world that also
drove the poor guy insane but as we see
later with the mind stone not all that
cosmic wisdom is just madness in the
beginning of infinity war the mind stone
definitely warned vision about the
coming threat of Thanos is it the stone
again as if it's peaked and recently a
lot of sources online had been
re-examining a scene in Thor the dark
world with Selvig rambling about
theoretical physics in front of that
chalkboard that was filled with Easter
eggs
this recent egg hunt really started with
a post by reddit user mush spurt and he
should really read their whole theory
because it is fascinating but here's the
gist if you look closely at each of the
terms scrawled upon that chalkboard
pretty much all of them described events
that would later occur in the Marvel
films at first a lot of these just seem
to apply to the events of Thor the dark
world
remember the convergence of the nine
realms but other stuff more closely
describes other events from Ragnarok
infinity war and man in the wasp leading
us to think some of these things could
happen in the next Avengers movie so
let's look at what this redditor found
and break it all down okay first we can
see terms like the alignment dark energy
distance mass and gravity forces the
nine worlds all of which are ideas that
come into play in Thor the dark world
however we should point out that Nineveh
Lear and moose Pelayo which appear in
that board are places that do not appear
until later loose bhai ms the realm of
demons that was ruled over by searcher
in Ragnarok and of course Nineveh Lear
was where Thor in a tree forged
Stormbreaker in infinity war but also
you can see the term phase transition
that is the concept that applies to the
events we saw an ant man in the wasp
remember the character of ghost was
suffering from phase shifting which was
only cured when the quantum healing
energy that Janet Van Dyne brought back
with her from the quantum realm earlier
in the movie bill foster lectures to his
class
about quantum physics including this
point if the system is interfered with
that stability becomes chaos
unpredictable dangerous beautiful in
other words the object in question would
be both in and out of phase with
multiple parallel realities ah basically
Marvel Morpheus is explaining that in
quantum mechanics particles can
transition between phases of matter into
multiple parallel realities at the same
time as we've suggested before in other
videos that could mean ant-man who's
trapped in the subatomic quantum realm
could transition into another parallel
reality from there and in the next
Avengers movie dr. Silva Queen au know
is alive could look over his old notes
and help explain this science to start
banner and the other survivors and maybe
help them shift into another dimensional
reality where events might have played
out differently that could be the key to
beating Thanos and look again at this
chalkboard
the set designers include a few fun
Marvel Easter eggs Simonson's theory of
relativity refers to Walt Simonson
writer of many Thor comics and creator
of the character beta ray bill whose
hammer inspired Thor's new weapon
Stormbreaker an infinity war there's
also six one six universe which at the
time was just seen as a nod to the whole
multiverse of the Marvel Comics that's
where comic characters exist within a
vast multiverse of different parallel
Earth's
our main earth being earth-616 by the
way this is basically how we get all the
alternate spider-men and into the spider
verse but now rather than just being a
throwaway Easter egg it kind of seems
like this could be more important
because maybe so vig divinely inspired
by the mind stone was the first to
discover the multiverse which could be a
real thing that the Avengers used to
defeat Thanos you can also see the term
Schrodinger's cat that's the famous
thought experiment that suggests that
particles in a closed unobserved system
theoretically exist in multiple
simultaneous States like a cat in a box
is both alive and dead you can read more
into this in your own time you may know
this concept as the basis of the
multiverse in Rick and Morty and perhaps
showing up on Selvig stock board it also
could suggest the multiverse existing
within the MCU
basically all the other terms that you
can see on this chalkboard could play
into this idea of dimension-hopping the
crossroads the nexus of all reality
fractal gateways connecting neutral
brains there's also the
which the redditor claims could refer to
a tear in the universe that nano says
snap might have created and that brings
me back to this new book synopsis we're
at the very end it referred to a new foe
that threatens to destroy them all new
foe as in the threat beyond Thanos so
this could be someone the Avengers
actually have to work with Thanos to
defeat in their next movie or maybe a
new big bad for phase 4 if you look at
the Infinity Gauntlet Comics vanishes
decimation disrupts a number of cosmic
entities there's eternity Chronos
Galactus The Living Tribunal gets
involved at the mess
perhaps in the film's thanasis Snap is
such a universe wide catastrophe that
even bigger godlike forces have to step
in which characters like so big start
banner Scott Lang and the rest discover
through their exploration of different
realities we already know one god-like
entity exists in another dimension the
MCU Dormammu hanging out over in the
Dark Dimension I wonder how he feels
about Thanos is that whatever it is he's
probably just one of many unkillable
evil forces just waiting to be stumbled
upon my question for you is which of
these characters do you think will be
that next threat after Thanos comment
down below with all your thoughts and
follow new rock stars on Twitter and
Instagram at new rock stars and for all
of my hot takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram @ ee vas and
subscribe to this channel new rock stars
for the deepest dives in the Marvel
Theory because you know we're doing
something right if our hero is a guy who
explains quantum physics with shoes any
questions can I have my shoe back
everybody's doing it